- [Announcer] This is pizza.
Now before you pizza purists
destroy us in the comments,
please open your mind and let me explain.
This is Zanzibar pizza.
(whimsical music)
- [Announcer] Meet Muhamedi.
He is the best pizza maker in Zanzibar
and is pretty well known
around his hometown.
Oh, I didn't know I was with a celebrity.
Anyway, Muhamedi is a fixture
at the Forodhani Garden Night Market,
making pizza both sweet and
savory for over 10 years.
Every morning Muhamedi
goes to the local market
for the very best and fresh ingredients
in order to make his one of a kind
homemade Zanzibar pizza pies.
The dough for Zanzibar
pizza is actually chapati,
an unleavened bread, which
is also made by hand.
Ooh, that sounds good.
And that, my friends, is
pizza - Zanzibar pizza.